republican congressman matt gates has
had
quite the year as it was widely reported
the justice department is investigating
whether he had a sexual relationship
with a minor
and paid her to travel with him across
state lines which could violate
sex trafficking laws he's also faced a
litany of similar allegations and
accusations
around inappropriate treatment of women
gates denies all wrongdoing
and maintains that he and his family
have been the victims of a quote
organized criminal extortion involving a
former department of justice official
seeking 25 million dollars while
threatening to smear my name
end quote if this were the case could
gates and his family even fulfill
such a high demand well according to our
figures
they technically could forbes estimates
gates and his parents are worth around
30 million dollars
based on financial disclosures filed
with the state of florida
and the u.s house of representatives
matt gates reported assets of 235
thousand dollars to 625 000
on his most recent congressional
disclosure form which requires
representatives to list most
but not all of their holdings his
parents don and victoria gates however
are among the top 1 don had reported the
couple's net worth was 29.6 million
dollars as of june 2020
according to a document he submitted to
the state's ethics commission
this portfolio includes publicly traded
stocks 13 pieces of real estate
seven figure stages in three private
companies 375 thousand dollars worth of
antiques
imported rugs furniture and books and a
2013 mercedes-benz s-class sedan
real estate is the biggest chunk of it
six coastal homes on florida's panhandle
an apartment in new york city lots in
four states and a stake in a pensacola
office building
the net worth 14.6 million dollars based
on realtor estimates according to the
disclosure
before moving into politics the elder
gates was a successful businessman who
started a company
vitus healthcare with two other
co-founders in 1983.
in 2004 the company was bought by
plumbing business roto-rooter
for 406 million dollars by that point
don gates was also serving as the
superintendent of florida's okaloosa
county school district
two years later he won election to the
florida state legislature
and became the state senate president in
2012 a position he'd hold for two years
it appears not much of matt gates's
parents money has been passed down to
him yet
in his latest disclosure he lists
ownership of several undeveloped lots in
florida
worth between 65 dollars and one hundred
fifty thousand dollars
as well as retirement accounts worth
between sixty five thousand dollars and
a hundred fifty thousand dollars